j'ai parlé un peu plus tôt avec le maire
de Laval Stéphane Boyer qui était
évidemment secoué on va en écouter un
extrait suivi de la ministre de la
Famille Susanne roi qui promet qu'on ne
va pas oublier tout le personnel de la
du service de garde les gens qui ont
besoin d'aide les gens et les premiers
intervenants etc que personne dit elle
vous allez l'entendre votre tomber dans
une craque on écoute
Monsieur le Maire bonsoir
bonsoir alors c'est un coup dur c'est un
coup dur vous l'avez dit ce matin
ça fait des années qu'on a des coups
durs c'est il y a eu la pandémie il y a
eu ceci et cela vous l'avez dur à Laval
celle-là dépasse d'un grand corps là que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour aider
d'abord votre communauté et vos
premières réactions ce matin vous j'ai
envie de vous demander d'abord quand
vous avez appris ça autour de 8h45
oui mais écoutez j'ai appris la nouvelle
ce matin je suis en réunion à l'hôtel de
ville donc on a mis fin à la Réunion
pour aller tout de suite sur les lieux
rencontrer les familles voir qu'est-ce
qui se passait évidemment les premières
réactions c'est
difficile de mettre des mots sur sur ce
qui se passe c'est la tristesse la
colère l'incompréhension
aujourd'hui plusieurs familles ont reçu
un appel qu'on espère jamais recevoir
dans une vie
et
c'était une scène quand même assez
difficile à voir
des familles qui couraient qui
tentaient d'avoir des nouvelles de leurs
enfants
[Musique]
et je pense que ce qui rajoute à
l'incompréhension ou de là évidemment du
deuil
c'est le geste en soi pourquoi est-ce
que quelqu'un
font très délibérément sur une garderie
où il y a plusieurs enfants
l'enquête nous dira un peu plus je
l'espère sur les motifs mais évidemment
aujourd'hui Laval c'est une communauté
en deuil
pour la pour les familles qui évidemment
ont perdu dans certains cas un enfant
pour d'autres que leurs enfants est
blessé mais c'est aussi bien plus que ça
aussi le personnel qui était sur place
la personne la garderie c'est le
voisinage et des voisins qui ont dû
intervenir sur la scène et c'est tout le
personnel d'urgence nos policiers nos
pompiers nos ambulanciers sont quand
même habitués à intervenir dans des
situations d'urgence mais cette fois-ci
c'est quelque chose d'autre quand on
voit un enfant qui vit sur le sol
c'est des images qui nous marquent et
donc aujourd'hui c'est toute une
communauté et moi comment lavage je veux
que la communauté réponde présente pour
pouvoir supporter chaque citoyen saxoine
qui est impacté mais c'était important
ce que vous dites donc comment ça va se
déployer cette aide parce que vous le
dites bien c'est un accident de voiture
sur un accident de voiture c'est
terrible ça peut décimer une famille
mais là il y a un geste délibéré
contre des enfants impuissants qui
étaient en train de jouer à la garderie
alors comment va se déployer l'aide pour
les policiers les pompiers les
travailleurs on parlera la ministre plus
tard aussi pour les éducatrices et tout
ça comment on s'arrange là
oui donc essentiellement c'est de l'aide
psychologique qui est offert donc
rapidement après l'événement on a occupé
une école qui était à proximité où on a
rassemblé les parents on aura rassemblé
les enfants où il y a eu du support
psychologique qui était offert et ce
sport là on va continuer à l'offrir au
cours des prochains jours parce que
évidemment dans les médias la personne
peut subir un choc peut être en
traumatisme mais des fois sous l'effet
d'adrénaline on peut se sentir bien mais
c'est le lendemain c'est la semaine
suivante où on va sentir les
répercussions pour moi c'est vraiment
important qu'on soit là pour nos gens
peu importe au moment où ils en auront
besoin donc il y a eu dans un premier
temps les services déployés sur le site
il y a des services aussi déployés
d'aide psychologique par exemple à la
STL à la société transport de Laval
parce qu'il y a aussi des de nos
chauffeurs d'autobus qui connaissaient
cet individu c'était un collègue qui ont
impacté par l'événement donc le service
psychologique a été offert sur place
mais le sera aussi sur les lieux de
travail et ne sera aussi au fil des
prochaines journées talent longtemps que
un besoin sera ressenti nous serons là
pour